Ayya everyone Hello, hello Sorry guys, I'm sorry making you
guys I did four loops I was like, I started a stream Yes,
we're in my We're sleepy bird today because I'm sleepy It
was 1230 and um I'm sleepy Meow
I slept really early too last night as well but it was I
don't know today I'm just today I'm just extra sleepy today
uh mr.
broken bond thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
yeah uh doki for a possible stream idea with the dragons
maybe can try e10 what's e10 I don't know eating my nuts the
super chat thank you thank you um no e and d e and d's nuts
yeah that's right i said it before you could finish the joke
i took it away from you i took the power away from you i got
him no i got you i that's fucking right i got you power from
you i i reclaimed it i i read that uh misdemeanor you did i
didn't give me the satisfaction uh slide thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you um what was that oh yeah um
anyway i went to use the bathroom i was like everything
looks like it looks good and then and i was like and I
started the stream and then I was like oh I need a bee and
then I finished being and then I was like oh I forgot to get
water I might as well it's looping and then I went to get
water and then I stubbed my toe and then I sat in my bed
contemplating life because I stubbed my toe and it was very
painful and then I came back you know I was like how many
loops were there and you guys Like, oh, I went to the
bathroom and I typed in the chat.
I was like, oh, I went to get water.
And then I stubbed my toe.
And then after that, I swapped to this scene.
And then here I am because I'm sleepy.
And then someone sent a super chat to me and was trying to
get, try to got me.
But then I got him back.
And then I explained my whole day.
And then here we are.
Here we are.
uh but today on on thank you thank you it's like a it's like
a netflix recap it's the amazon prime slash netflix recap
that explains everything but also nothing at the same time
um say jen thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
um is it yeah my toes okay don't worry it's it's okay i
swear to god i i the one thing i hate about streaming
services now is that good tv Like, not even good TV.
But any TV show is now one hour long.
And it takes fucking two years to film in between seasons.
And I'm just like, bro, I don't...
I don't remember what happened.
It doesn't matter how good.
Like, I might as well just wait until the show finishes
before I watch anything.
because it like every time I watch a new season of like the
newest hit show like Severance I when the Severance season 2
came out and I was like what the fuck happened in season 1
but like I remember season 1 being really good but it was
also a fucking mind fuck so then when I when he showed the
recap I'm like I don't remember any of this I was like I
sort of vaguely remember but also like I don't remember.
And, Kat, thank you for the...
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Yeah, it's like...
It doesn't even have to be a hit show.
And the thing is, Breaking Bad was like...
Did not take that long to film in between seasons.
And what?
What was it?
Breaking Bad...
Episode length.
Was it one hour or 30 minutes?
It was one hour.
Okay, it was one hour.
But it didn't take like 20 fucking...
Oh, shit.
I'm Tanya again.
I forgot to...
fix this oh no give me a sec i pressed the wrong button oh
no i need to turn that off that wasn't supposed to happen
let me fix this real quick all right where was i i got sorry
i got up i got really passionate i got up there we go i
think that's where i was unless i was a little closer fuck
it
I didn't see who raided, but thank you so much for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, let's fix this.
I don't care.
I know you're in my immersion.
It's okay, all right.
Now I'm back to normal.
Um, wait, was that, was this the same?
Was it, was, was I this close or was I closer, guys?
Uh, Mikey, thank you for the raid.
Thank you, thank you.
Was I closer or was this the right position?
Guys.
It's fine.
Yeah?
Or was I closer?
Okay.
Alright.
Closer.
Okay, fine.
Because you guys complained about immersion.
Let me...
I disappeared.
This is even more immersive.
And then...
There we go.
Now, am I close enough, guys?
Or do I further?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Oh, even closer.
All right, that's close enough.
That's as close.
Or, or I'll be like, whoa.
I think you can see my little, my little sleeve there.
All right, here you go.
You can see a little dragon down there, too.
All right, let me lock it in.
Sorry, today's a pretty chill, because I feel very chilling
right now.
It's, it is.
very early for me and by early I mean it is 12 30 p.m.
and that is too early for me so I might sound monotone
because I inside I'm dead inside understandable right now
I'm dead inside there's no soul in this body uh we're a
youtube inch anyway but like i said i this is what i hate
about modern tv shows now because um because everything
takes two to three years uh two to three years to to produce
and then like and then and then i just forget everything and
I swear to God like and then like the actors just grow up
way too fucking fast because you're like You can't even get
child actors anymore because like like by the time it's
season two They'll be like 25 years old at they start the
show at like 13 and then see by season two comes out They're
like 25 and they have to still play like a 15 year old or
something I like it was like what was it um anyone who ever
watched oh, yeah like avatar the Netflix adaptation it's so
fucking funny because I was like Tanya's hell and then like
season two come the season two previews came out and then
he's like taller than like all the actors now because you
don't expect it you know because they haven't gone through
puberty so you're just hoping that um you're just hoping
that the kids will the the Tanya kids would like their
puberty will have like a growth stunt or some shit like they
just don't hit it and now ang is like taller than saka now
yeah and then it's like it was like the adams family too um
if you ever watched wednesday i haven't watched season two
because like um because like in season one um apparently
like they got rid of all the plot points that came from
season one um because one of the actors turned out to be
like I don't know like really bad one of the actors was very
important to the whole overarching story of Wednesday and
was supposed to continue in season two the actor got fired
so so so they have to scrap the entire storyline and then
come up with a new storyline for season two so I don't
remember what the fuck he did but I I don't keep up to date
with that stuff I just know he did a apparently um i don't
know bad enough that he got fired it's like the avengers
where um um we're like what's his name the whole story that
was based off of that tang right there there was the whole
overarching story was supposed to based off tang of the
multiverse stuff and everything and then he got fired so
then they had to rewrite the entire avengers plot line
because like after follow up uh Thanos because there he was
the next big bad and then and then and then he got fired
because he did a really bad thing and so they're like what
the fuck do we do and then that's why there was a whole gap
in between like throwing random shit um on the board to be
like what do we replace gang with and that that's why we
have yeah but then apparently we're supposed to get like we
were supposed to get the the new avengers movie a lot
earlier because it was based around king and that the scrap
the entire like because like they write like 20 years in
advance or some shit but at least we got dr doom but the
funniest shit is that dr doom has no room apparently they're
like um apparently the leaks were saying that mr Fantastic
does not have a big role in the film regarding a film about
Dr. Doom.
I was just like, but they're rivals, though.
Yeah, I was just like, how...
What?
Yeah, it makes no...
I hope that's just bait, but like, like, the directors were
saying, like, um, yeah, it, um, Fantastic Four will not have
like a huge role in the new doctor the new Avengers movie
and I'm like but there that but his doctor to do became
doctor doom because of the fantastic four and like they're
like lifelong rivals it doesn't make sense and then and then
another leak um is that saying that like oh doctor i hope
it's all bait because none of this is making sense the more
we learn about the new avengers movie the less sense it's
making for me but anyway they were saying like oh um doctor
do like because he's being played by robert downy jr who is
also like you know tony stark they were like oh yeah he
there's no relations between like tony stark and dr doom And
I'm like, then what's the point?
Why does he look like Robert Downey?
Why does he look like Tony Stark?
Then what?
He just loves Tony Stark.
He fucking got plastic surgery and was like, make me look
like him.
I hope, yeah, I hope that is, um, I hope that was also bait
because I just, like, why would you, like, I hope it has
like some, it's like an alternate universe.
there is a one plot line where um dr doom and robert downy
jr like swap bodies or some like an alternate universe where
dr doom and robert downy jr swap bodies and then he like um
he basically was like you know he was tony stark uh sorry
like i said robert downy jr but he practically is tony stark
right now um like that's like his entire role um but like no
with the um with the tony and like and that was an actual
plot line in the comics i hope it's like something like that
where um where it's uh where he just took over tony stark's
body in a different universe and just wants to conquer the
multiverse or some shit also i read i know this is like so
off topic about what our stream was supposed to be but uh i
also read that um during the filming of the Avengers movie
uh Robert Downey Jr literally has like his entire his own um
what is it called his own like room like casting room was it
called casting room what is it called like their own actor's
room what is it called where they have the trailer and stuff
the trailer part
yeah he has like yeah it's called Downeyland and no no like
uh like when they have their when their own little like
place for whenever they do breaks and stuff and they go to
their own trailer park but there's a special is it just
called trailer they go to their own trailer but anyway
dressing room yes so he so robert downy junior has his own
dressing room but it's called downy land like all the actors
know where he has like his entire like a bunch of trailer
parks a bunch of trailers um just dedicated to Robert Downey
Jr. And, like, he just has, like, his own chefs.
Like, literally, he has his own private chefs and
everything.
So he doesn't go out to the catering stuff to eat with the
other actors.
Um, and, like, he literally, like, yeah, he literally has
his own land.
Uh, where all the staff, like, serves him and stuff.
Yeah, he has entire convoy.
It's crazy.
Uh, yeah, but, like, it's in his contract, apparently.
it's his own little village during like uh during um during
the films filming of the fucking avengers movie bro yeah bro
is legit tony bro bro he like for his last birthday for his
last birthday he was literally just tony stark he had a he
had an iron man themed birthday party like a tony stark
birthday party i don't know his last one or the one before
but i saw pictures of it is literally he just became the he
just became what he he became his character this is beyond
method acting at that point where was it let me see i could
find pictures
but he literally was just like i'm iron man now because i
might as well be iron man
He is Iron Man.
Let me see if I can find it.
I found it.
I saw it on Twitter.
But Robert Dutley Jr. birthday.
Oh yeah.
He has an Iron Man cake too.
Is it this?
He literally had an Iron Man cake.
Like that's me.
I don't even know how old.
Bro he's 60.
Holy shit.
60 now he looks really good for 60 gotta be all the botox
i'm sorry i'm sorry bro you cannot be like no it's all
natural no this it's no like look at anne halfway that
there's no way that's natural like anne hathaway is 43 and
they're like wow she looks so good for it bro it's botox
there's no fucking way.
I refuse to believe that her skin is that tight at 40 years
old.
There is no way.
When you have the money, you don't have to worry about
aging.
Like, what's her name?
Um, no, I don't believe celebrities can take care of
themselves, um, to look that good because celebrities they
have to go through extreme weight loss and extreme weight
gain for film roles and also filming like um they might have
to like film for like launch like x amount of hours too and
then press tours and the stress of like the stress of
publicity and everything and um and you know because like
streaming as well like you know the stress of numbers and
stuff like
like press tours and having your entire life be monitored by
paparazzi's and doing you can't if you say one wrong thing
like they'll demonize you and everything there's no way
there is no way and also I if you guys don't remember he was
a drug addict for for like 10 plus years His not even 20
plus years of his life.
So there's no way he fixed that like
There's no way like his like at 60 his body was like it's
all right.
We're better now
It's possible.
Yeah, I know some people forgot some people Forget that Wow,
it works, yeah, that he was a big drug addict for, like, 15
to 20 years of his life, but then he got better.
But his body was so fucked up by then.
Patra as soon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That was the character training arc for Tony Stark.
Hi, Ed.
Um, yeah, oh, yeah, it's so weird when they lie about it.
Yeah, same with, like, what's her name?
It's so weird.
There's so many actresses and actors that lied about getting
plastic surgery or Botox because their entire fucking face
changes.
Um, what was her name?
The actress and the boys and then Sadie, was there any
other, the Stranger Things girl?
What's her name, Sadie?
Like, you could tell, like, they got plastic surgery
because, like, Because, like, they can't do emotions
anymore.
They got plastic surgery and Botox because, like, they can't
emote anymore.
Like, they're like, now be sad.
And they're like,
you're like, are you sad?
You're like, I am sad.
And you're just like,
yeah.
Yeah, because they can't move their face because the Botox
makes it really hard.
to make your face go up and down um it's a closed mouth
you're sad and sad and then the what's her name the girl who
does like starlight in the boys she was like i didn't get
plastic surgery okay um it's just lighting and i'm like bro
you're bro you're what happened to the cheek fat in your
fucking jaw like she's like always weight loss and like it's
like what your nose like bro what I did not realize weight
loss puts like removes an entire bone on her your nose like
entire yeah I was just like there's an extra bone on your
nose what do you mean weight loss
um yeah no she looks so different I'm really sad that
because like she was so I think she looked really cute
before she got plastic surgery slash um the cheek whatever
like there was a new for those who don't know there's a new
Hollywood fad right now uh for actresses and actors where
they literally removed the fat from their cheeks because
they don't later like because they want to look more I guess
serious or more Like I guess like Greek statuesque type type
style, but like I think I don't know I was like you looked
so cute before I thought you looked like A lot of people
looked really good with the fat like in their cheeks Like is
that but like yeah that was it called the the boot gal fat
removal So yeah people like the muing suit.
Yeah like the muing shit You think gave you all these bones
being Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And I think people look better with the fat.
I don't think the... I don't know.
I think the sunken cheek look is not attractive at all.
It's just... I don't...
My personal opinion, it is not attractive at all.
I think it makes them...
The fat removal makes them look a little bit more ugly.
I think they looked a lot better with it.
And also, like, it's so weird when it jumps between seasons
and then, and then, like, they just don't look like the
person before.
And I'm like, what happened to her?
And not to look them.
Because, like, that's what happened to me for Starlight and
the boys for the new season.
When the new season came out and I saw her, I was like, who
the, what the fuck happened to her?
Who, like, I was like, did someone starve her?
Like, girl, are you not getting paid?
Like, oh my god, are you not making enough money in the
boys?
Like, who's feeding her?
And then I Googled and they're like, oh, she got plastic
surgery.
I was just like, oh, she got, oh, she got plastic surgery.
She got that shit removed.
That's what happened.
Like, someone, please give her a sandwich.
Anyone.
Mr. Broken Bob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I know Doki is going to need Botox to do all the laugh last
you get in the future.
What a shame.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, oh wait, what else?
Oh, man.
There was something else I want to talk about regarding.
I know we're, no, I know this is very off topic from what
the stream was originally, but let me, you know what
grandma's my ideas.
This is, this is celebrity talk with Doki Bird.
um this is trash talk what was it trash taste
um oh there was something related to like plastic surgery
and stuff i'm trying to remember real real quick um um trash
yap yeah i forgot trash taste already exist i forgot about
that i don't Legally, legally distinct podcast with Doki
Bird.
Yeah, I forgot that was a thing.
I was like, oh my God, that's such a good title, guys.
That was such a good title for a podcast.
That's going to be my new title.
And I was like, oh, wait, it actually exists now.
Never mind.
Trash Yap.
Yeah, Yap-y Bird.
Thank you for the super chat, Pop.
a swerve.
Thank you.
I'll get her.
Welcome.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Uh, Patreso, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, stream idea.
We plan a cookbook where every food item must include a
tomato.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Legally distinct garbage yaps.
Um, but yeah, anyway, that's celebrity rant of the day I
know I I have actually do have really um like I said for
those who are new to watching me um for those who are new to
watching me um I love trash shows I love trashy shows and oh
yeah oh yeah I remember now what's your name like the
Kardashian mom the Kardashian mom she got plastic surgery
recently who is her surgeon like get me his number unrelated
I just I just I am an admirer I am I'm not I'm not getting
plastic surgery but I will I want to look at his other works
because I'm like that that is crazy like she aged backwards
um for those who don't know like Kim Kardashian's mom what's
her name like she she like Kate like they fucking all love
plastic surgery by the way but Like, it's crazy.
I need to know.
It's insane.
Like, like, she actually, like, there's no more wrinkles.
I was like, where did they all go?
That's the shit.
But I, like, I just want to look at his other work because I
was like, that, that ain't, that should not be a thing.
But let me see if I can.
Let me see if I can get it.
a picture comparison for you guys so you guys can see.
Okay, it's Chris Jenner.
Okay, Chris, sorry.
Like I said, I really do have trash dates.
Like, I keep up with tabloids and like, like celebrity news.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that your Oshi is like this.
I like, I like, unironically.
So for those who are new here, um for those who are new here
i i used to i used to watch very trashy reality tv shows
like princess and tiaras and um and back which one princess
and tiaras and my strange addiction and um and i keep i keep
up with like celebrity news on yahoo back then what yahoo
was a thing you know in yahoo and Yahoo they have the news
tab and everything so I would look at like celebrity news on
Yahoo for the articles and be like oh what's new on
celebrity news right now and then you know those TMZ
interviews where they're all in the TMZ room and they're
like oh my god did you guys hear about I didn't watch Jersey
Shore though that was too trash even for me that was
actually too trash even for me I had I had a limit I had a
limit to the trash I consume I also unfortunately did not
keep up with the Kardashians um oh I watched wife swap only
because my mom watched wife my mom was trashy in terms of
like she she consumed a trash reality TV shows so I consumed
trash reality TV shows with her so she would watch like wife
swap and like she watched like um like those home home like
uh Those like home redecoration chat shows.
And like she was the one that introduced me to Desperate
Housewives.
And I was way too young to be watching Desperate Housewives.
But I...
A generational garbage watch it.
Yeah she continued.
I continued the cycle.
I was too young to be watching Desperate Housewives.
But like I watched it with her.
I think she watched sex in the city.
I don't know.
I thought sex in the city was like I never watched sex in
the city.
That was my limit.
I thought it was I think I watched one episode with her on
TV and then and then I was like this is boring.
I thought it'd be like more sexy.
But then it was just women getting brunch.
It was just women getting brunch.
I was like bro what the It's like turn back desperate
housewives.
I want to know who's cheating on who next I'm not like true.
Yeah, it's just that's what sex in the city is and they're
just they're just going for brunch.
Anyway, let me show you the transformation.
It's actually insane.
Like I'm like I like like when I saw this I was like at that
point I'm like bro that's just like magic like what happened
to her fucking there's no wrinkles no more this is it's a
magic burned up surgeon
that surgeon's a fucking witch like like she literally aged
backwards
yeah because it's like really hit or miss plastic surgery
Because, like, I mean, I already told you, like, examples of
it.
So, I'm, like, like, bro, do you know how old she is?
She's, like, okay, how old?
She's, like, 80 or some shit, right?
She's 70.
This is, bro, she's fucking 70.
That's insane.
Yeah, I was, like, 80.
They're, like, it's all at the same age for me.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's 70.
saying that's why i was like what what else does he do i
need to see his portfolio because this shit is magic the hag
is that yes
that's why i'm like that's crazy anyway what was i talking
about before i got before um or was i just talking about oh
yeah the trashy shows i used to watch um and even then i
consumed trash from twitter too so I like how Twitter has
been renamed X for X amount of years.
And we still call, we still call Twitter Twitter.
It just sounds better.
Bro, Elon Musk has been trying to fucking make X work for
the longest fucking time.
For those who don't know, he tried to make PayPal X.com as
well.
But then the board of directors was like, no.
He actually got voted down because even the board of
directors at PayPal was like, that's fucking stupid, Mr.
Musk.
Like, we are not renaming PayPal.
And then he bought Twitter and it's like, finally, I can
make my dreams come true.
We can finally make my dreams come true and call it X.
Alright, anyway.
Let's actually start the stream.
Our 42 minutes intermission.
So, I really want to get back into making creative streams
again um so uh i would love to have your input and your
ideas on what streams you guys want to see um it's not more
like more like oh i want to see you play x game i want to
see you play this game or like i want to see you collab with
this person or that person it's more so like creative ideas
like i wrote some stuff down i've been like brainstorming
myself too for 2026 and i want to go back into more creative
fun ideas um and so just playing video games um so here's
some examples um i wrote down um for like ideas and stuff
wait let me see where did i wrote my examples give me a sec
i i did write examples but i need to scroll up and find
where i write it uh wait is it not here is it in games
oh okay so so examples will be like uh you know i've been
watching doug doug again recently um um just because i was
like trying to think of stream ideas and so some of these
things so you know how so uh i'm thinking of hiring a
programmer to let us think of make like cool stream like
cool chat interactive games together so one of the things i
want to do is like a battle royale So, basically, what Doug
Doug did is he set up a code where it will pick random
chatters in chat and then put them through tests.
And then chat will vote off who to kill based off of their
answers.
So, like, we can give them, like, answers, be like, oh, give
it, like, oh, tell us your favorite game.
And then, like, the random people we picked will be like,
oh, this is my, and then be like, convince the chat and then
and then they give their favorite game and I'll be like chat
kill off one person that you think has the shittiest taste
and and then and then basically something like that like
yeah the chat hunger games yeah why is it always about I
just gave one example and then another thing that he did I
talked about it before but he was like okay To the
contestants, pick one random person to die.
And then they're like, everyone talks.
And the people, the, the chatters talk to each other.
And they're like, okay, we picked this person to die.
And then, and then Doug Doug was like, JK, now the person
you pick now has a knife.
Now you, your entire, the entire chat picked you to die.
You pick one person to kill.
So it's like absolute anarchy.
that's really fun um you know i like that tango thank you
for the super chat thank you we are not we are we are not
drawing beatros thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you so these are like you know these are some ideas um like
an example of what kind of streams that we could do in the
future another example i wrote is that watching animal cams
like live cams um because that's not playing game where well
you know you know how zoos have like animal live cams and
also twitch too
um and like you know we could watch zoo cams and stuff or
like like those what live cams do they have anyway there's
like not just animal cams but there's like a bunch of
there's live cams around the world of different things and
we could like people watch too that's not creepy
oh my god okay yeah there's like earth live cams in united
states oh we can look at oh my god there's a live cam right
now philadelphia pennsylvania we could literally people
watch yeah
it's not yeah we could actually people watch them and judge
them the world.
Oh, let's go to Italy.
What's all going on in Italy right now?
A view from Fort.
I'm going to Italy, guys.
Uh, Brandino, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Totally not creepy at all.
These are like some ideas.
What else is that right?
Chat helps or sabotage Minecraft playthrough.
uh voice command mario maker um what else oh i love the okay
i was watching one of my the one i really like but then i
think it'll um i think it'll be like uh really hard to
program because he programmed it himself it's like i must do
anything the richest chatter says and it's so fucking funny
because it was just they're like and they're like honest
download this game and then played this game and then like
by the time he finishes downloading some other guy like some
other guy donates and becomes the richest chatter he's like
i just saw that game play my game it was it was really i'll
show you i'll link the video it's actually really fucking
funny because he was just like please i just want to play
like one game just let me play And then like some guy was
like ban the last richest chatter And then ban the last
Because apparently if you ban someone They can't even They
can't donate again So then he one of them was like Ban the
last two richest chatters And and uninstall steam So no one
can play any game And it was like it was crazy It was such a
good video And then in the end, all the money went to
charity.
So, you know, it was not like, you know.
I'm in charge now.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
When the Dougberg crossover stream happening.
Dougberg retired, guys.
I don't know if you know.
A lot of really big streamers.
Retired recently.
I mean to be fair.
He's been doing this for a while and it's like he's he's
Doug Doug is like super fucking great Yeah, in his newest
video.
He posted a retirement video But it's more so like he just
wants to do whatever like he just he just wants to he's
going the PewDiePie route This is how I found find out on a
don't keep her stream where she's talking about celebrity
trash and then I find out how you find out um so um yeah so
he's he's going um he's going to PewDiePie route and
basically just doing whatever he not chasing numbers anymore
because like he's made it basically he has enough money to
basically just make fun content that content that he wants
to make no he's He's not that route, but just, he has made
enough that he just wants to do what he wants to do for the
rest of his life.
Because I assume, like, you know, he makes enough.
He makes enough invest in other stuff, like go into
investment and what's the other thing?
What else?
Is it just investments?
Or there's a word for it.
You know, when...
Um...
Is it investment?
Where he has, like, other means of income.
Day tree.
Yeah, passive income.
He just makes it up and then just diversify and has passive
income.
To the point where he doesn't have to, like, stream to make
money anymore.
Yeah.
Because, like, that's what people should do when you make
enough.
By the way, adult advice, I know you're...
You're like, adult life advice from Doki Bread.
I don't know.
I should take life advice from you.
But if you make enough money, like the smartest thing to do
of your income, if you're not living paycheck by paycheck,
is to look at passive income.
So that, like, you know, you like, so that you build up your
passive income and look into investments and stock market
and stuff like that.
Or, like, you know, housing market.
um just to make sure you have passive income in the future
when you're older so when by the time you retire um you
don't have to worry about like oh i can't retire yet because
uh because i need i don't have enough money uh when i'm like
40 years old or 50 years old uh 50 plus years old so i have
to keep working i think that's also a problem i know like um
i know like there's like a problem right now where a lot of
like the like a lot like like the elderly um are still
working because they don't have the funds to retire uh so
because they're like oh i can't retire yet like i can't take
care of myself if i retire now so they just keep working and
working and working until like until you know they just work
themselves to death but yeah it's actually really smart to
just um by the time you have enough money to start investing
in other things you have passive income um anyway little
life advice because like you know how like football stars or
like i feel like streamers a lot of streamers invest too a
lot of like the really big streamers like i think i'm pretty
sure dug dug has passive income like that guy is fucking
smart as hell um but like a lot of like sports like people
were in sports um they don't look into passive income and
that's why like football stars they would make millions of
dollars per year but but that by the time but then they
would go bankrupt uh they go bankrupt like uh within like a
few years because they don't have passive income they just
keep spending money they keep spending spending spending
yeah anyway to my manager um don't judge me because i i i
know
And I was like, oh, why don't you, yeah, you, why don't you
take your own advice, huh?
Imagine side-eyeing me right now, just like, you know what
to do, yet you don't do it.
Don't do what I do, do as I say, not as I do.
Imagine, like, oh, so you do know how to be smart with your
money.
You just choose not to.
I say as I spend a thousand dollars becoming the duchess of
sea land.
I guide others to treasure I cannot possess.
But we can be happy now.
Exactly.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I could invest in passive income by investing in youtubers
is more fun uh mr broken bond didn't give the super chat
thank you thank you i will be the richest dragon thank you
the super chat thank you thank you thank you first time
super chat what about playing games with dokey mods and them
love the milgare solid delta streams by the way thank you
thank you for the super chat thank you they all love too
that's what i'm saying i want higher i i'm in talks with a
programmer that mods mods like people into games too but i
think type deal but it'll be fun I get to play as me um um
but I would love to do that I'm just into I I just added a
programmer on discord and to talk more about stuff I think
the hardest part is that YouTube chat is not like as
customizable as Twitch so like that's like one of the
hardest things about seeing what I can do if worse comes to
worse um I can just have I can just use just have to have
twitch chat open to type in commands and stuff like to have
the interactive part but we can still be on youtube um we
just have to have like you just have to have twitch chat
open yeah the chat api apparently is like yay twitch no no
not twitch streams we just have the chat open we just we
just have the chat open i mean i could do dual stream too i
mean either works
one dead guy thank you this richard thank you thank you i
recommend ui challenge ones for games such as manga man okay
yeah um i don't mind i don't know about mega ddr matt but i
oh yeah someone i have long time ago i don't know but it was
on my other account um i had dm dug dug on how he did his
voice commands with mario maker i bought all the stuff for
it but i don't remember how to set it up because i don't
have i don't have the dms anymore so maybe if i dm dug dug
he'll tell me again i just hope like he responds yeah i hope
he responds because like you need like like a special a
special equipment for the uh for the mario maker like to for
like voice chat mario maker um and and i bought it but then
i i forgot how to set it up because it was a long fucking
tutorial like he sent me like a lot of words I remember I
was like oh my god that's a lot of instructions um so I need
to like ask him again and be like can you can you like you
know give me the step by step again because I don't remember
uh and seven thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you artist option to submit create MP4 export timelast of
dokey commissions for thumbnails as grouping weighting rooms
in image bindings.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, that's cute.
That's a cute idea.
That'd be a cute thing to do for like a week or so, but it's
not really a stream idea.
It's more so of like just a starting screen thing.
But it is a cute idea.
I think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Maybe I'll do something not in the future.
I didn't.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Send for all the saskatchas i don't okay this is my hot take
i'll do a hot take right now um but i don't think like i
think eye tracker cams is like it's annoying because like we
all know what i'm looking at So it's like, I don't, I don't
really like the you, I guess like, I don't really like, um,
I don't really like the, like, like the, you know, like, you
know, like the UI thing where it feels really annoying to
look at on stream, but that's just me.
I just, I don't know.
Because it's like, it's like this like circular thing that's
all like flies around the screen and stuff.
And it feels like you do it one time.
Like you do a stream like that, like once or twice.
So like for me, I just, I find it like, I don't know.
Because we all know what I'm looking at too.
Like I'm not shy about it.
I'm like, ass.
And like, like I even, I even, you know, I've given.
them a little pat too for good luck i'll be like pat pat
wish me luck
i will be staring
oh and george thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you chat choose a rice cooker for you and you do a cookie
stream with it i do want to do like hand cam stuff in the
future it's just i'm always so paranoid about it so i never
have a chance to set it up also like um also like i need to
ask people like what their setups are because it's so like
i'm always like super paranoid about like what if i like hit
the camera thank you for the super chat that you did what if
i hit the camera you see a you see my floor and be like i
know where she lives It makes me paranoid.
I think I need to move to a new place if I ever want to do,
like, an actual CanCam stream.
Because I do want to open, I want to open, like, oh, no,
that's so bad.
I know it's going to be so bad.
Because I have a gotcha box problem.
This is why I don't do gotcha with my own money.
You know, like, you know, like, um, like the sponsor
streams, they, obviously, they, like, you know, I'm not
using my own money when I do the polls because it's like
they give me money and I use that money to do polls that
doesn't sound very that doesn't sound very smart but but
like oh gotcha boxes um yeah yeah I I do have if if I ever
go to like those like miniso or um or pop mart or like the
how what was the other one the other one it's not pop mark
but um
catch is it gotcha box is that what they're called or what
are they called the little the blind boxes okay blind boxes
um what are they called okay there's another one too it's
not Popmart or Miniso.
There's another one.
But I don't remember what they're called.
It's not pop.
There's like a third.
Was it my plastic heart?
There's like a third store that sells blind boxes.
And I can't remember what it's called.
What's it called?
Oh, is it 50?
What is 52 toys?
Maybe.
But anyway, I have a problem.
I have a problem.
that sells blind boxes I go in and I come out with less
money so I feel like I but and then like you know what I do
with the blind boxes after I open them it stays in a bag
tucked away in a corner because I I open the blind box it's
done I got the I see what I get I'm like oh that's cute and
then I put it back in the box in the bag and then in the
corner I don't even I don't even display it it's just the
thrill is gone you know the chase is the high is gone I got
my fix and then off and then the cycle repeats itself yeah
the little rush of dopamine I did it for the thrill And I
got my fix and I put it away and I'm done and I get on my PC
I do it for the love of the game Yeah, I got my dopamine.
That's why I'm saying I have a problem.
I really do So it's like the moment I do hand cam streams,
we're gonna be opening blind I'm like guys guys it's blind
me box opening time guys what if i want to sell blind boxes
as merch guys oh my god i'll give you guys the thrill how do
i do that you get like a blind box acrylic standard so i
don't know i don't know what's in it but i'm like i like you
get it guys you get it you oh my god i'll give you that rush
you know sell that rush to you as well Jeno don't spread
your addictions it was Gotta collect them all It's all dog
shirts Oh my god I could do Oh my god you know like the In
Japan they do like the End of the year Um It would just have
the dog shirt And it's just You open it It's the dog shirt
I will take your entire stock, Zechra.
Thank you for the Hakka Sufa.
Thank you.
Like potentially it could be something else.
Like the dog shirt is the commons.
And then the rare.
And then we put the like the 0.1% chance you get something
that's not the dog shirt.
500 dog shirts.
No, oh my god, you know, okay, so you know in Japan They do
those, um, oh my god, I'm writing the blind boxes I want to
make blind box merch now Alright Blind box Blind box merch
Anyway, um, yeah, you could get a, yeah And then a 0.1% is a
sign Dog shirt Signed by dad No, please Guys, guys, you
could potentially get a side dog shirt, guys.
There's 0.1% chance.
Yeah, with a paw print.
Okay.
What was I saying?
Oh, but yeah, in Japan, they do these, like, end of the year
lucky bags.
But it's just them getting rid of old stock.
I could do that.
The 2026 lucky bags.
It's just all dog shirts.
It's just, it's just, it's just, dude, it's like, do you
want the 500 yen lucky bag, the 1,000 yen lucky bag, or the
10,000 yen lucky bag?
So the 400 yen lucky bag is one dog shirt.
The 1,000 yen lucky bag is two dog shirts.
And then a thousand yet the 10,000 yen lucky bag is 10 dog
shirts and then maybe a sticker and And then maybe maybe you
could get a sticker too and the 10,000 Yeah They give value
yeah in Japan a lot of stores they do that like um there's a
lot of stores that do Like the end of the year lucky bags,
but they're just they're just stores trying to get rid of
like try to get rid of old like old stock or like extra
stock unsubscribing uh she had to give me a super chat they
can thank you for selling your blind boxes that's blind
boxes for charity backtoress so they give a super chat thank
you thank you you could win anything even why a white shirt
for your dog i'm a lover thank you your super chat thank you
thank when we get the gang back together for a payday three
collab thank you the super chat thank you thank you did i
play payday 3 i thought i think i played it with engine
thank you thank you thank you i don't have any good id
content ideas but i do have a solid financial advice for
gasha you can't lose if you never stop that is true that is
true um marco thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you no game in the idea instead of a concert for an event
why not produce a play musical since you're a fan of
theaters and stuff also hear me show dog cert sellathon
trust me it would be really funny oh yeah i remember like
shy lily did that she did a sellathon where like buy like a,
what was it?
Was it Celeston?
Or like she did a thing where every time you buy something
related to her merch on gamer subs, like it added a timer,
basically so that the stream goes on longer or something.
I could do that with dog shirts.
And then the entire stream is just based off It's dog themed
related.
It's a dogathon.
Every time.
Every time you buy my dog shirt.
I'll stream a little longer.
Yeah, it's so dog shit.
Yeah, no, it's so much.
Yes, I thought it would be a hit market.
I really did.
I thought there would be a market for Hawaiian shirts for
dogs.
I'm the only market I'm I'm the only market she was not
cooking with that yeah but the dog shirts are comes in big
sizes too guys turkey merch.com turkey merch.
guys guys turkey merch.com I did it it comes in small medium
and large oh shit your corgi needed to large okay maybe guys
sorry small to medium size dogs maybe not large dog I did
not realize that that um that the large only the large fits
the corgi Silent, I'm not revealing the sock because then
it'd be too sad.
It gets too real.
It gets too real if I tell everyone how much we have left.
Not again.
Anyway.
Answer it.
You feel it It's okay We released I released the dog Files
They released the dog shirt Files Wait Per variant Or are
you saying Combined Wait Silent Is it per Per size Or like
Or like Is that all together Because if that's all together
Then it's
there's no way because that's not a rounded number you're
fucking with me oh oh it's all together okay no okay it's
all together okay i got he said pervariant i was like that's
not a round number there's no way that's pervariant that's
that's in total anyway here's the link to a dog shirt guys I
would unironically I might do a dogathon now okay I'm
writing that down dog dogathon you buy a shirt we extend the
calendar the stream calendar and it's like I need to get rid
of these shirts hey guys if you guys No, imagine if you
stream for 30 minutes.
Can you keep?
I'll be like, one shirt is like five minutes.
At least, I'll be generous.
I'll be like, one shirt is like 15 minutes.
My corgi.
Look, I have a happy customer.
Happy, happy customer.
Jayla Cohen, thank you for the super chat.
They can thank dog shirts for charity.
Think about it.
How many dogs?
Oh my god, wait.
I could do it so that you buy the shirt and then you could
choose to donate to it to a dog shelter.
That is okay.
Wait, you buy the shirt and choose.
So if you don't have a dog, I can just donate the shirt to a
shelter.
I'm cooking.
Guys, I'm cooking right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like, we don't have...
Yeah, yeah, that's such a good idea.
I'm writing it down.
I just bought this shirt.
Yay!
What do you mean scammed live on camera?
It's...
We're donating.
You're donating.
Sorry, not me.
You're...
You guys have to make up for the sales of the shirt.
I think you spent so much money making these shirts.
You're donating it to charity.
Let's see.
Solid Snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dogathon.
Each shirt is a treat for dad.
Bye bye bye.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Just put the money in the bag Dragons.
That's your answer.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
On the bright side, we are chibi.
It's the same Well, right?
We see the soul crushing despair In your eyes when you
thought the number was like Three to five times.
You know If you, this is why I'm not revealing I am not
Revealing the number because It's too sad.
It gets too real.
If I tell It gets too real.
Thank you For the super chat.
This is only for me and my manager's eyes only simple thank
you let's super chat thank you thank you just giving away
the dog shirt as the taxi ride off thank you let's super
chat thank you thank you what size fits a weiner dog um
either media i think media might be the best one medium uh x
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you for okey
dokey lokey pokey smoky bird thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you um that is for my eyes only i will not
reveal anything more about the shirts it's oh my god okay so
i have a background idea and then i'm gonna put the dog
shirts in the background like i'm having a background a new
background drawing um and it's like the outside um and then
they're asking what easter eggs i want i'm putting the dog
shirt in as an easter egg i'm i'm gonna write dog shirts
the sky is just the look Dog shirt, lucky bag.
Yeah, box of just the shirts.
It's a lesson to me.
You know, be like, sometimes what you...
Sometimes what you think might be a really good idea.
And that everything, everyone will want might just be you.
You might be the only market for this idea.
You might be the only market.
You and me, they give the super chat.
Thank you.
You can make it a dad flush and have it come in all sizes.
That whole, that whole, oh my God.
And then you could dress up your dad.
You can dress up your dad flush.
Oh my God.
Wait, it's like those, it's like, it's like those pet
stores.
You know how in the pet stores they have those weeners?
It's always a weener dog too.
Oh, yeah, no, I want to make that too.
I've been wanting, sorry, my manager sent me, like, I still
want to make this merchandise idea.
I think that would sell.
I think, I think that, I think there's more, that's not for
dogs.
So, like, it's a bigger market.
Like, there's more, you know, I realized that not a lot of
people own dogs.
Or, okay, so, so I still want, I mean, I drew this on
stream.
So, I still want to make this, guys.
Your manager is, like, you can show it.
I still want to make this.
And I think, I think, I think this is a more successful
market.
Because, because like, more people wear underwear than they
do have dogs.
Guys, right?
I assume more people wear underwear than, like, we're boxers
than have dogs who need shirts.
So, because, like, you know, sometimes it's crazy, but I
realize that some people have their dogs naked.
and they don't close their dogs and I realized that was also
a little thing that I didn't take into account but I know
for a fact that 99% of us here wear underwear might not be
boxers but they wear underwear yeah so so so that is a good
market I there's no way I can fail for this one that is and
I there's no way I can fail for this one the dog shirts
where it might have been the worst idea I've ever had but
but but I learned my lesson and it's like I I learned from
my mistakes guys and now I diversify it's a mouth print ours
is it a flat print we'll figure that out later We'll
workshop that idea.
Uh, Yumi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You can make, uh, this is the worst idea so far.
You, uh, JPNG, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Build a dad workshop.
Oh my God.
What if I create my own build a, build a bear?
But we're dad.
And now I make outfit.
Okay, no, that's really bad.
I just need to stop cooking, guys.
But I need to stop cooking.
I create a plushie where you just put you buy it so you can
put the dog shirt on you know like those okay but you know
those like weiner it's always a weiner dog but they always
like do these outfit um those like to put on outfits um like
a little like a weiner dog mannequin I swear to god this
I've seen this everywhere at pet shops too and it's always a
Don't understand, like, you're not, like, is there no other
dog breeds to put clothes on?
Like, you guys seen these, right?
At Pet Star?
I swear to God, I see this everywhere at Pet Star.
It's like the Weiner Dog mannequin.
I swear to God.
I saw it, like, around the world, too.
Like, it's not just, like, in NA.
I see it, I want, I saw it in Japan as well.
I would just, like, you know, like, want to buy outfits, and
they have, like, a fucking Weiner Dog mannequin.
shit whoops let me reset transform there you go yeah it
would look like this it's a weenor dog mannequin to put
clothes on to try clothes out i i swear to you guys see it
like in all the and like like like i'm not all of them but
whichever pet store that has like a dog mannequin and i
always see it's always a weenor dog
have that I got a dad version
uh let's see you patch your red suit thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you no matter which side of mouth is in
it's in the wrong spot need a super chat thank you thank you
I might need more water you guys I'll be right back I'm
gonna get more water I am
back I also got myself cop drops too morning My soul has
come back, so my body wakes up.
Not really.
It's like three out of four soul, like the blue man.
That's why he's blue.
He doesn't have his soul.
It's crazy.
I can't believe it.
When you don't have like one fourth of your soul, you turn
blue.
I learned that you got out of war.
JPNG, Lacone, Mehdi.
Zekra, Chris, Rice, Forward, Broku, Nexi, WB, Papa, thank
you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, well, yeah,
Smurfs have no souls, yeah, like Smurf is not even a real
Smurf, she's genetically engineered, so she's not even a,
she's not even an authentic Smurf, that's why she's the only
women, because all Smurfs come out, come out as men,
apparently, I don't fucking know how it works a lot
biologically but all smirfs are yeah she's literally ai
that's just yeah she's a gmo genetically modified organism
she's literally smurfing
can't believe rihanna's a smurf now i can't believe rihanna
is smurfette and that movie surprisingly did really well
because it was in the top 10 animated films wasn't it i'm at
top 10 20 25 i was like who the fuck was oh and then they
like they like what did they do where is it 10 animated
films ah where is it where the is the chart okay top 10
animated films grossing 2025 it popped up on my twitter and
i was like that can't be real oh it wasn't oh wait no that's
the highest grossing movie where the fuck is animated films
there was an animated films one oh yeah lilo and stitch is
number two by the way global box office number one is um
what is it it's so tiny it's on facebook you guys are two
leo and stitch which is crazy that is leo and stitch leo and
stitch minecraft zutopia 2 Jurassic world demon slayer how
to train your dragon f1 the movie superman and then tom
cruise and that's just like high grossing films not like
animated movies I don't know about anime films though, but I
saw a smurf, a smurf movie in there, and I was like, that
smurf movie?
Yeah.
Oh, did they lose money?
Okay, they deserve it.
Like, that movie was bad.
I didn't even watch it, but I could tell it was bad.
Yeah, I just thought it was funny with the, uh...
With the...
What was it?
Influencer Smurf.
Yes!
They made an influencer Smurf.
That shit's crazy.
Influencer Smurf.
It lost 80.
It deserved to lose 80 million.
Yeah.
Thank God.
They actually replaced him.
Because everyone made fun of him.
And then they literally canceled him live.
Like, like, cancelled him in the next trailer.
So, like, um, so, like, the trailer dropped, like, the
premiere, Smurf premiere.
And everyone made fun of Influencer Smurf.
And then the next trailer drops, and they literally just
removed him.
He disappeared.
They got him.
They, they, they got him, guys.
He got cancelled live on Twitter.
immersive they literally just fucking remove the guy and
they replace them with another character they replace them
with vanity smurf i know too much about the smurf for a show
i've never watched all the information i gathered from the
smurfs is literally from robot chicken and family guy
because like i just i saw from the pop culture references
from robot chicken that like Like, learn about the Smurfs.
I don't understand.
I never actually watched their real lore.
Like, I never watched, like, watched any of their actual
content.
Oh, yeah.
Anyway, back to...
Back to stream ideas, guys.
Yeah, the Smurfs have lore.
Oh, and Goff Smurf.
When Smurf Red turns into a Goff.
She turns into a Batty.
Yeah, they made Vexi, who's a bad girl.
And then she turned Smurfette into a bad bitch, too.
So they made Goff Smurfette.
Yeah, they did.
They made...
It's a Smurf about color.
Wait, okay, this is when they did realistic Smurf, so it's
ugly.
So be warned.
It's a realistic Smurf.
But they made a baddie.
And then they made Smurf.
And then she like sucked the color out of Smurfette.
And then Smurfette became a baddie too.
No, that's not Smurfette.
This is like...
This was like Vexi.
Vexi the Smurf.
What's her name?
She has Smurfette and Smurfette's sister.
Who originally was a naughty.
What the fuck is a naughty?
naughty is that what smurf what oh it's a genetically it's
an actual gmo genetically modified organism a genetically
modified smurf but they're called baddies or sorry naughty's
they're actually called naughty's what the fuck okay so
they're called naughty Is there even like an article about
what a naughty is?
Please, we need streams where you teach us math, English,
and history.
We are, bro, you didn't, okay.
You're getting a stupid person to teach you about his, like,
to teach you about, what is this, drunk history?
Oh, I would love, wait, actually, drunk stream where I
explain the plot about something.
Drunk stream.
Drunk stream where I try to explain.
blame the plot or a history of something uh it's like i i
chug a can i chug a can of cider and i try to drunkenly
explain riverdale again to you guys i'm not caught up with
riverdale i stopped when i stopped during the part where
jughead goes to a unit like goes to a private school and
then his teacher jumps out the window because the actor got
fired That's where I stop.
You know what's even sadder though?
The writers of Riverdale at least know what Dungeons and
Dragons are compared to Stranger Things.
I've only watched season one of Stranger Things because I
thought it was just all right.
Like I didn't think like it was like, you know, like it was
like, oh it's a cultural phenomenon to me.
It was just all right.
From what I read, apparently, Stranger Things.
Stranger Things whole thing, the theme of it was based off
of Dungeons and Dragons.
And like, but the writers, the creators of Stranger Things
has never played Dungeons and Dragons before.
So they're just making up shit on the fly.
They never even played Dungeons and Dragons.
They would just be like, I guess, I think that's what they
do, Degs.
Like, I was like, you don't even bother to research it.
Apparently they didn't even like, they did like the bare
minimum of research.
search um for dungeons and dragons
so um so but but like in riverdale it was more because like
the thing is riverdale they had an entire plot line based
off of like a parody of dungeons and dragons called oh my
god what was it called so it was more it was more true to
dungeons and dragons it's called Gryffins and Gargoyles, G
&G.
So, I forgot how fucking stupid that was.
Okay.
So, so in Riverdale, they had like an entire season
dedicated to G&G, Gryffins and Gargoyles.
So, they were actually playing a Gryffins and like a
Dungeons and Dragons game.
But it was more, it was more faithful to D&D than what
Stranger Things did, apparently with D&D.
I can't wait to play G&G, Griffins and Cargill Hills.
When did that season come up?
Seven years ago.
Seven fucking years ago.
Oh, it's neat.
They give us super chat.
They give thank you.
I still have it.
I wanted to do it, but I wanted to do like hand cam.
Like I said, I think whatever.
Whenever I move to a new place, I feel like I just need a
bigger room for it too, for all the stuff.
Yeah, I still have it.
I still have the jar.
It would be something in the future where I want to have
like, I want to move to a new apartment or something for it.
We have a bigger streaming room too.
for it to have a setup for handcams and stuff because i'm
just like super paranoid i'm like because my room's not that
big so like i'm always paranoid that i'm gonna fucking knock
my camera down or some shit this is not a really big room so
did we watch the dnd movie for watch that mr broken by i
think of the super chat thank you thank you i actually
watched the movie i thought it wasn't bad i don't know why i
think like the timing for the movie came out in a really bad
time Because that movie was actually pretty decent.
I liked it.
I wanted to do a Men in Blackwatch along for members.
Which reminds me.
I need to make a tweet about the member stream.
I think the server is fixed now.
I'm pretty sure I fixed the server.
Because I remember when it first came out.
People were like, oh, this movie, the movie bombed.
It didn't make that much money.
Or it didn't make that much money in the theaters.
I think also, I think back then, Dungeon Dragons were still
pretty niche.
But I think, like, nerd culture has now become...
mainstream now because nerds grew up and became billionaires
so now everyone's like i don't want to be a nerd now i just
think like nerds nerd culture has become oh and the pandemic
dude nerd culture has become much more um um mainstream yeah
nerds have more money
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Speaking of D&D, how about one shot with the sloppies plus
Nimi fries?
Nimi has experiencing DMing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That would be fun.
I'm really bad at role playing, though.
I didn't ask the worst.
I don't know.
Maybe if I was somewhere.
I mean, I could write that.
That's actually a pretty fun idea.
DMing.
D&D.
D.
I think, like, um,
I think like I'm for me I'm just nervous about Dungeons and
Dragons Because I feel like I personally And there's just
really bad at roleplaying Because all I do is just play
myself I just Or I play someone I was gonna say Or I play
something one really stupid But then that's just me I just
play like a version of myself I feel like Yeah I feel like
I'm just really bad at role playing because when i did the
when i did my first dnd session um um with like some of my
friends on stream with rochella or those who watch rochella
um like the people i was playing with they were so good at
role play especially gully oh my gully was so fucking funny
i don't know you guys know gullibles um but we just like
stream with him before but he was he was like so good at it
bro like i i don't even remember what character he was but
like he'd like he fucking gave me a 10 every time like
beyond he was always going like 11 out of 10.
Next seat they give him the super chat thank you thank you
roleplay is off stream a good bit and can be funny about it
they give the super chat thank you thank you
yeah gutters gutters i remember gutters the fighter i am
gutters the fighter
for his like gutters knows what to do and like gutters no
yeah i have rochella 2023 oh my god let's just stupid dude
bro i'm fucking good he was so good um because he he was
really he does he actually does uh gollos actually does dnd
too a lot so so he's like oh my god gutters the fighter Oh
my gosh, Gunner's the fighter!
The Gunner's the fighter.
Oh my, I forgot.
That was such a...
That's such a good name, bro.
That's actually such a good name.
He's so good at roleplay.
I'm so jealous.
It wasn't even emotionally complex character.
It was just fun.
Everyone just plays the facet of Rochella was amazing
Patrick has seen the US Super Chat Thank you, thank you
Yeah, it's so freaking smart That's why I'm always very
anxious about D&D Because I feel like I personally am not a
good role player Because I just be myself That's why I never
did the GTA RP Because like Because I'm so bad at
role-playing.
I just want to be me.
Because I'm already a character.
I feel like I'm already, like, such a character in itself.
Because I do, like, dumbest shit.
Sometimes that it's just more fun to be me.
Yeah, I'm already silly goofy.
I role-playing every game.
I just role-playing myself.
Oh, to be fair, I roleplayed the extreme version of whatever
character I'm playing.
I think that's, I think I'm always play, I'm always
roleplaying as a more extreme version of whoever the main
character is.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Tossing up the idea out again.
What about Dragon Talent Show?
We can submit art, music, art, like acts like comedy and
magic tricks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
yo that would be fun it's like those like streamer talent
shows and stuff that's fun i think i think it's more so like
my staff will have to vet the stuff because then i have to
like not be able to see what the stuff is so i can be
surprised but then i don't want to be mean you know we
always need a simon on the show well you know like if it's a
talent show you always have to have the guy That's super
positive about everything.
The Simon of the show, who's like always negative no matter
what.
And then, yeah, we need a Simon.
And then we need the middle judge who can be mean, but also
nice at the same time.
Like we need a, yeah, we need a Randy, a Randy, a Simon, and
then the woman.
I forgot her name.
I'm sorry.
I just know she's, I just know she's a woman.
Paula, Paula Abdul.
Yes, yes.
We just need Simon, oh, Randy, and Paula Abdul.
Don't you name, name five women.
Fate, they give us the...
Magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
No idea, just repentance.
It's bad.
We won't talk about it.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
Bro, I didn't remember Randy.
I saw someone in chat.
I just remembered Simon.
That's not true.
I only remembered Simon and Katie Perry, but she comes in
later.
I remember, I remember, but I was, like oh but she wasn't in
season one of american idol so she doesn't count and so i
didn't name i didn't name katie parry i was trying to think
of the season one of american idol and it was simon that's
all i could remember because everyone remembers simon new
stream idea joki name a hundred women she's gonna beat the
allegations all right i'm very back i gotta be like we are
back
I am back.
I have to blow my nose too.
Uh, bye.
Nexy.
Forward.
Mike.
Solid.
Medi.
Uh, NSD.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What was that?
Oh my gosh.
Speaking of the name 100 women.
I remember I saw a Twitter video um, where the guy named
like 100 Pokemon He did it in like less than 10 minutes.
And then someone was like, okay, name 100 women right after.
And then it took the guy like an hour plus.
And people were like, wow.
He's like, he took the bait.
Like, bro, why did you take the bait, bro?
Why?
Like, bro, you fell for the bait, bro.
And that was fucking hilarious.
Like, I could give 100 Pokemon.
I was like, all right, now name 100 women.
Right after.
I'm the woman that gives nothing burger opinions.
And the men is Ryan Seacrest.
The tire of the randy.
Snuffy ass to Sally Min.
That's a good panel.
Oh, my gosh.
I hate being sick.
Uh...
What the heck?
What?
What is this?
Oh, okay.
There was like...
I got DM about a sponsor, and I was like, What's this?
I don't remember the sponsor.
And then I looked at it.
I was like, oh, this sponsor.
Oh.
It's all blurring together.
I, but yeah, I hate.
Um.
I hate, uh, I hate being sick.
Cause it's just a cough.
Honestly, I think it's just a cough left.
But it like comes in randomly too.
I didn't go to the doctor.
Because all I have left is the cough.
So I don't feel like the need to.
um but but if the cough is still around by the end of this
week I will go to a doctor because I do have a lot of
important things I need to do and like I cannot be coughing
for I cannot have a month or two long cough guys not again I
always say that but it's always again but not again this
time this time it'll be different I
think it's also because I've been streaming Because, like, I
think that's why my recovery stopped, because I started
streaming again.
Because, like, before, like, I was recovering super duper
fast, because I wasn't streaming at all.
And then I just kept, I don't know, I went back to
streaming, and then my recovery just, like, slowed down in
general.
Because I'm talking a lot, too.
i love streaming also i need i it's my job so i need i need
to have income
tts stream i want to have a little dragon that talks when
you guys when not for a gaming stream but when i'm like
chilling that there's like this new this animal crossing mod
that you can use as your tts now where it makes you sound
like crossing characters but also like um I mean those are
always fun you know like the TTS stuff but little animal
crossing characters that talk
yeah I want to do that also that means I don't have to read
it's a win-win I don't have to read no more
but if you're talking in animal crossing language then i
have to read but i meant like if you're talking in like like
actual language then like i that's the real intention not
reading yippee
oh man make you guys sound like joe swanson oh peter I
wonder if I can make a TTS that just sounds like me So I'm
talking to myself Like you're my voice You could be the
voices I'm going to write that down Programming TTS Where is
my voice So it's like I'm talking to the voices in my head
You guys are the voices
Ha ha ha ha
Kongu, thank you, but then you can actually hear my voices
now.
Kongu, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh, I already read that one.
Uh, sorry, I scrolled too far up.
Han George, thank you, thank you, thank you.
India, no talk stream or collab song to talk for you while
you play games.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's not fun, it's fun, though.
I like talking.
The trash yaps.
Aphelion.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What about green screen VR chat where you take requests in a
second stream to watch drag goers make with waves?
Totally didn't steal this idea from Jerma.
Yeah, I totally didn't steal this idea from you.
Thank you for the super chats.
Thank you.
I'm pretty sure it didn't mint that's...
something similar?
I remember.
She did a stream like that too before.
What are ideas?
I'm going to look through my idea notebook that I wrote
down.
I want to do a stream.
I collab with someone where we give shitty advice to
viewers.
But we have a disclaimer.
We're like, please don't follow our...
You guys like send in like like streamer, streamer.
Yeah.
What do I do and blah blah blah and then we give like the
shittiest advice spots
They'll be like please do not follow this place in general
Do not do that people will do it
That's not true.
I give good advice Sometimes it's like a 50 50 There is a 50
50 chance
head I am trying to like Oh this one
Would you Would you listen to Advice Can you not would you
listen Oh my god I can't English right now I can't Would you
take Advice from a person whose Face is like this Amazing
Sorry I'm getting way too immersive Right now I'm getting
way too in character.
Can you?
Yeah, such good advice.
Surely you'd follow...
Surely you'll follow my advice, right?
I want to play Neopets, the darkest fairy.
This is not related to the creative.
I just really want to play that game.
But I have so many games I need to complete.
Like, I accidentally started.
way too many game series and I can't start another one I
can't start oh wait did I write this down I want to do like
you know that market plier and most critical game series
that they did where they play five random games like they
play five random games in the news store
like on itch.io or like or like or on the news store front
page I think that's really fun to do.
We're just like, we're just Gamba.
Or three.
Three is a good amount.
Five might be too much.
Yeah, we use dumpster diving.
Steam dumpster diving.
Or we find dead games that might have zero player base.
Bro, you know what was a fun game?
I don't even know if you can, you can like, uh...
I don't like using the word, the e-word, because, like,
people can get really freaky about it.
But what was it, the Pets, Pets, Pets game?
From Neopets?
Pet, Pet, Pet, Adventures!
I really want to play Pet, Pet, Adventures, but it only came
out on the PSP, and it was such a fun game.
I don't like saying that word because of my corpo training
because like if you say if you're in a company and you say
that word um you get in a lot of trouble so so it's like
ingrained in my head to avoid ever saying that word out loud
because it's for those who don't know outside of NA it's you
can get in really big trouble outside of na because it's
very frowned upon so like it's so i don't want to get in any
trouble
no you can actually like you get like it's actually really
it's like um outside of na it's like you can get like find a
lot of money or like get banned from tournaments or it's
just like public wise it's like very frowned upon outside of
na like if you like mention it like you can get in a lot of
trouble because for those who don't know i remember it was
like really crazy so even modding stuff because like modding
things is also like a huge no-go too outside of na um for
people who this but um in in the smash community there was
this very uh like there was this pro player in smash from
japan that modded their that modded their console to fix the
lag from um yeah to fix the lag uh from the queuing system
um for smash brothers and then people found out and then he
basically got like a two-year ban from like tournaments just
because like he modded his consoles to make it less laggy
yeah and it like and every like everyone in japan agreed
about it it's actually crazy because it was like a huge um
culture shock for na people um because like in na people
were like what the fuck like everyone mods their stuff like
that's not new and in japan everyone like agreed with the
band and be like no that's the right thing to do like yeah
no he was cheating but then in na people were like the smash
players in na in the smash community was like no this is a
wrongful band like you should reverse it but everyone japan
was like no this is a right band like he was he was um using
an advantage against other honest competitors so it was a
huge like culture um like is that the word like a huge like
is it culture shock there's a word for it but but different
reactions from different cultures.
He didn't do it in a tournament.
He did it on a stream.
Like culture class.
Yeah, culture class.
Yeah.
Like, it wasn't even, like, on...
For a tournament setting.
It was, like, a stream.
It was, he did it on stream.
Yeah.
And then he got, like, mega banned in Japan for tournaments
and stuff because of it.
streamed it in japan because he forgot to turn it off i
think that was the story i don't i think that was it right
he accidentally had it on and then he would like he like
went to turn it off but then people already were like oh
wait you have a modded console oh yeah
so it's different it's like a culture clash yeah because nap
i remember like people in anywhere super confused um people
i don't remember it was like two plus years or something but
yeah people in n a were super confused and uh and then and
like barely that because like you know it's a different
culture like n a people love modding stuff and in general
but modding things is like very frowned upon outside of n a
in general it depends it depends it depends on the game it
really depends on the game because i know like hollow knight
and silk song is has a lot of really fun mods in general,
and a lot of them also comes from, um, China, because China,
uh, Chinese fans really love, like, uh, Hollow Knight and
Silk Song has a huge fan base in China, um, and a lot of
really fun mods came from, um, the Chinese fans for Hollow
Knight and Silk Song.
Was it two months?
I was two months I got confused about the dates But I know
he got kicked out of a tournament That we were supposed to
show up in
Yeah But yeah anyway I really want to play Pepe Adventures
The One I'm wishing But I don't know if like it's possible
Is it?
Let me check It's one of my favorite games
It was one of my I never finished it too I play that game
every day I think Neopets had a really good had really good
like um games in general
yeah but I want to know if and if it's like popular enough
to be able to have it be played oh they do nice I just
looked it up oh never mind wait let me double check I didn't
know PSP works for it as well oh never mind don't trust
these websites
I clicked on the website and I was like I don't trust this
website guys I I don't want like I don't want my information
to be stolen
yeah the weird ass links
too late we have your info we found out you're Canadian
No!
How did you know?
How could they find out?
My Oshi is Canadian.
What do I do?
The Tokeybird Canadian situation is crazy.
Oh my god, it's been two hours already.
Holy shit.
Time flies, guys.
Time flies when I'm having fun with the...
goons
what's this time really fly
fuck okay sorry I'm always I'm very entertained by myself
it's very easy to entertain me let's let's go let's fucking
go okay the rest is true the last remaining stream will be
like this because I feel every morning oh I feel every
morning me when I stay up me when I play Rivals last night
what two hours goes to a motherfucker I'm having fun just
relaxing and chilling with you guys this is more of a this
was this definitely more chill stream and we got off really
fun ideas it was more of a yapping stream but we had some we
had some really fun ideas though yeah we just bobbing we
hang out
what are ideas guys i'll do final call final call it's like
we're at a restaurant and like i swear i fucking hate the
final call system like i understand close the kitchen and
everything um but if they say like you know if they're
closing at 10 like you know they're closing at 10 p.m but
final call was like i don't know 9 p.m then you're closing
at 9 you're you're you're fucking closing at 9 you're not
closing at 10 p.m i
remember like i went to like i really wanted to go to a
restaurant um and i was like oh it's closest at 10 and
that's literally what happened i like got there at 9 15 and
they're like we just did our last call and i'm like but what
what do you what do you mean i walked there by the way i i
um i i walked there for like 15 minutes because i was like
oh i don't need to uber this it's like it's like a five
minute uber i might as well walk there and they're like
whoop sorry we already did our final call like like 10
minutes ago and i'm like it's not 15.
i assume i assume i had time because it closes at 10.
alan thank you for the super chat thing thing go keep going
to random rabbit holes on i feel like that's every stream
though i every stream where i am i just go into the the most
red we learned a lot about smurfs today uh and trashy
reality tv shows and celebrities uh thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you kid thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you uh usb usb cable from a psp they make
psp av cables oh thank you the super chat thank you thank
you i heard like modded ds's are so expensive in general
right now because only like Two, was it?
Only like two companies make modded DSs where you can stream
it.
So it's like, so it's like really hard to obtain.
But thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm looking through the chat right now.
Let Chat vote to spend 1K of your money.
Oh, is that from, yeah, I had that written down actually.
Like I give you guys, like, I remember, what was it?
I think it was Ludwig, right?
That did something like that.
And also, Michael, when he fucking let a goldfish buy, like,
spend $1,000 of his money.
Was it a goldfish?
Oh, my God.
I wish I was, sometimes I wish I could program because I
would love to, like, just buy random stock.
Like, let chat pick.
Chat picks random stocks for me to invest in.
take let me take investment taking investment advice from
chat i'll give us a budget i'll give no way don't do it this
will go guys okay but like i'm not gonna spend thousands of
how to lose money there's a game for that is it my buy the
dip to buy game stop because i'll keep I can't stop stocks
right now.
I want to go wrong.
It's like...
By the dip!
You ought to make me money.
Okay, guys, maybe, though, that's a bad idea.
We fake buy stocks.
Chat picks random stocks for me to fake invest.
I'll be like, guys, we're only spending like $10 per stock.
If we make money, I'll reinvest in it.
No one can go wrong.
I remember always buy Costco stocks.
It always goes up.
Oh,
Kungu.
Thank you, thank you.
Soft docky challenge?
Like, I mean, this is technically...
This is sleep-deprived docky challenge.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you have any Apex customs plan?
I haven't seen you bullying any Quicks pros in years and I
have a craving.
I mean, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I would love to if the servers are not shit right now.
was in a tournament i think like a couple like a month or
two ago and like every time we started we started the match
everyone was lagging and like i think like one like during
behind the scenes yeah it's it's apparently really bad i
don't know if it's still bad though is it still bad or did
they fix it or for custom servers they think did they fix it
because i know regular servers fine.
I just don't know about the custom servers.
I'm going through chat.
Backtracking right now.
Yes.
Connor has.
Oh, that sucks.
Yes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You have to top 500 anything but Marvel Rivals.
Bro, like I, I'm like, okay, I didn't want to say anything,
but I I played a little bit of Overwatch on the side and I'm
like I thought I was like close to top 500 and then I found
out they fucking changed the system so so I'm literally like
I think I'm like master one right now um because like I know
GM is usually top 500 um I played a little bit like but like
okay you know what's fucking stupid you know how they're
like you need to play 750 games to be eligible for top 500 i
am at like 500 like like overall like for overwatch 2 you
have to play like 750 games in overwatch 2 to be eligible
for top 500 um because like i didn't play a lot on my main
account i've been playing mostly on my like when i first got
top 500 um in overwatch 2 it was on my alt account it was on
my side account not my main account and and so i was like
okay um i'll try and get on my main like i played out i want
to play a little bit on my main account because i don't care
as much anymore and also like streamer mode too to be
eligible you need to come you need a win by the way it's not
even complete sorry jk it's not even complete you need a win
750 games mode and be eligible for top 500 you gotta win 750
not complete 750 so yeah so like i'm at like 500 something
i'm so far from it so i was just like bro fuck that shit but
also um yeah i was like i got to masters one but like i
didn't play that much i think i played like 20 games i think
i was like 20 games and i got to masters one because i did
placements and i did like 10 more games i placed like master
something and i got one like a couple games and it was like
master one um and um usually gm gm threshold starts at like
sorry usually top 500 threshold starts at gm but um they
changed the top 500 for overwatch and everyone was like not
being like this sucks because the new top 500 leaderboard is
pay to win like sorry not pay to win it's like play to win
it's play to win not pay to win sorry there's everything is
paid to win now but like it's play to win so like people in
diamond are top 500 because all they do is play the game so
so you get these every time you play a game you get these
points and it's like uh whoever has the most like it's based
off of the points of how much the game.
So that's top 500 now.
It's not your rank.
So I think like rank five, the guy who's ranked five is a
master's player.
Because all he does is play the game 24-7.
So he's literally a master player.
That's rank five.
Yeah.
It's total.
It's like, top 500 play time not top 500.
It doesn't matter if you win or lose.
It's just I think the more wins you get the more points you
get.
So it's just how many whoever has the most amount of wins I
guess because you get challenger points.
So you win points and then the more points you have the
higher ELO you are yeah so it's top 500 whoever has like no
job I guess
because it's like how are you playing if you're how do you
get the enough points the no life is top 500 Kirikou's skin
enthusiast more than like that's your resting thing even the
super chat thing it's the most unemployed it's crazy I was
so sad because I was like, oh, I could be eligible for a top
500 in Overwatch.
And then other than the fact that I had to win 200 more
games, I was like, bro, I'm going to, I'm, fuck, no, no,
fuck this shit.
It doesn't, like, it doesn't, if I'm fucking masters and I
get top 500 because I played too much, like, that's just sad
for me.
I was just like, like, I need to look in the mirror.
I feel like this is who you are now because I feel better if
I'm like you know GM or even champion because now I'm like
okay at least like it feels better you know but if I'm
master like that's my wake-up call if I'm master I'm top 500
I'm like I like that's my wake-up call like that's the point
play to win like total playtime is fucking stupid Because
that's not your actual ELO.
Yeah, like, master player being higher than champ players.
Because champ players, when you're champ or GM, you also
have to wait a long time to get games as well.
So there's no...
Like, if you're, like, a high ELO player, you already have
to wait a super long time to even get into a game.
But if you're a master player, you get games instantly
because there's a lot of master players, too.
I play for fun.
this this info doesn't affect me because i play for a while
what a carefree life you live that guy spax 96 you're very
employed and i applaud you he he's like i have a job I'm
very proud of you.
He has a life.
Good for him.
I'm not jealous at all.
I'm not jealous.
I'm not.
Yay.
Employment.
That's sadly true.
Damn.
Bro has a job.
What the fuck?
um gaming thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
uh golden hell thank you the super chat thank you thank you
uh oh my god i feel like let's put it up um let me let's put
daddy on here yay goodbye dad you teleported out all right
oh my gosh i just realized all right i'm gonna call it here
guys because we do have another stream well it's a member
stream another member stream well not another but you know a
mem a member stream tonight i need to disassociate for a
couple of hours i need to recharge guys i need to charged
now uh before the next stream but it was really fun i always
love hanging out with you guys i always love hanging out
with the dragons i hope you guys had a fun time yapping with
me and we came up with a lot of really fun ideas to do for
2026 i'll definitely look back into the chat um later on
another time to just like write down any ideas that you guys
were spitting out that i didn't um i didn't notice but thank
you guys for brainstorming with me chat Thank you.
I hope you had fun hanging out.
I always enjoy these little hangout sessions that we do.
Anyway, guys, I have another stream tonight.
It's a Zom Project Zomboard.
We have two, I think, including tonight's stream, it'll be
two more Project Zomboard stream because the server closes
next week.
Yes, the server closes next week.
Most likely, we will do our final Project Zomboard streams
on Monday.
Oh, my God.
A Monday stream?
Yes, because I want to be able to host one last gathering
with everyone.
Before our infamous Battle Royale.
Because before a server closes, we always have a final
Battle Royale with all the dragons.
And I think that will be really fun.
Anyway, guys.
But not today.
Today is not.
Today we're going to do the plan for the Monday stream.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
checked.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you say it for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Well, I guess.
Bye.
And also buy the dog shirts.
Because here's what check out.
We're going to check out the dog shirts, everyone.
Check it out.
Bye, everyone.
Bye.